[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a science fiction thriller film
called children of men
spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
the premise of the movie is set in 2027
female fertility has become non-existent
for the past 18 years and doctors are
lost to explain the reason
with no women reproducing humankind has
not had a new child born in 18 years and
the world is falling apart
most of the world's societies have
collapsed due to war and paranoia of
extinction of humans african and east
european countries collapse and the
people migrate to other wealthy nations
the uk has become a police state because
of the increase in the number of illegal
immigrants and the police have the
authority to arrest any they find
at the beginning of the movie we see the
news the world's youngest citizen
argentine baby diego who was 18 years
old had died he was murdered by an angry
fan when he refused to give them an
autograph
the newscast is watched by a saddened
and stunned crowd in a fleet street
coffee shop humankind is facing the
likelihood of its own extinction a man
named theo farron enters the coffee shop
seemingly indifferent to the news story
or the crowd
just after he leaves and stops to add
liquor to his coffee the shop is blown
up by a bomb
the act is attributed to an underground
gorilla group the fishes
theo is shaken by the incident and
leaves work early under the excuse of
being shaken by baby diego's death he
instead visits his friend jasper the two
drive to a well-hidden forest home where
jasper lives with his catatonic wife
janice they live a secluded life and
grow cannabis in the place
the following day while walking to work
theo is kidnapped by two men who put him
in a van and drive off
the people reveal that they are an
organization called the fishes who
protest against the british government
to provide equal rights to every
immigrant
it turns out the group is led by theo's
ex-wife julian
julian and theo had a son named dylan
who died in a flu pandemic 20 years ago
the two had not seen each other since
she first tells him that the fishes were
not responsible for the bombing of the
cafe the previous day then one of her
group angrily claims that the government
bombed the cafe trying to create
discontent for the fishes
julian wants theo to make fake transit
papers for an illegal immigrant with the
help of his cousin who works in a
government sector theo visits his cousin
and is able to get the papers but they
specifically state that theo himself
must accompany this immigrant out of the
city he agrees and he with julian her
associate luke the immigrant key and her
midwife miriam drives to the southern
coast of england together on their way
they are stopped by a car in flames in
the middle of the road soon a large mob
of people attacks them everyone panics
and luke starts to drive the car in
reverse
however a person in front of them shoots
julian dead
as they flee the scene of the attack
they are pulled over by the police
when asked for their papers luke kills
both policemen a short funeral is held
in the forest for julian
theo breaks off temporarily from the
service and cries privately for julian
luke is able to find another car and
drives them to a safe house on a farm
where the fishes gather
theo tells key that he is going to leave
and the fishes can take care of her
however she starts to take off her
clothes
theo is stunned when he sees that he is
eight months pregnant everyone in the
fishes knows this and claims that it is
a miracle
the group then discussed what should be
their next move and theo insists they
should make the pregnancy public
however the fishes claim that the
british government would take key and
her child away and use them for their
own benefit they lead the decision to
key who agrees to stay in the custody of
the fishes
at night luke wakes up to a commotion
outside and sneaks out to see two
injured men arrive at the house
one of them is julian's associate and a
sociopath named patrick heaves drops on
luke and patrick's conversation and is
horrified to figure out that julian's
murder and the riot were all planned by
the fishes they want to use key's baby
for their own needs presumably to make
money off her moreover they plan to kill
theo the following day after hearing all
this theo panics
he quickly goes into keys in miriam's
room and tells them that luke was behind
julian's death before her death julian
had told keita trust theo before
everyone so she believes him he takes
the two women and sneaks out of the
house
theo disables all of their other cars
gets the women inside a car and narrowly
escapes them theo then takes them to
jasper's house since it is hidden and
secluded arriving there jasper is
surprised to see keep pregnant and
agrees to help them
he makes arrangements for ki to meet a
ship called the tomorrow a vessel
belonging to a group called the human
project a collection of scientists based
in the azores off portugal and dedicated
to restoring human fertility they are
the only people that will help key
genuinely the following morning the
fishes somehow manage to find jasper's
home
this sets of an alarm and alerts them
theo quickly gets everyone in the car to
take them to jasper's friend sid who
will help them get to the tomorrow ship
in a boat
theo key and miriam watch the fishes get
to jasper from afar
when jasper refuses to talk they shoot
him dead
theo is frustrated and saddened by his
friend's death but gets inside the car
and continues the mission anyway the
three reach an abandoned school and stay
there until a car arrives in the
compound
inside the car is jasper's friend sid
who happens to be an immigration officer
the plan is to get the three arrested as
immigrants and send them to the tomorrow
ship in the immigrant bus sid takes them
to a refugee camp where they see the
military killing the refugees one after
another throughout the way he goes
through contractions and whimpers in
pain
miriam who was a gynecologist before the
infertility pandemic helps key with the
contractions they successfully managed
to get on the refugee bus and head
toward bexhill on the way keyswatter
breaks and she is about to give birth
an immigrant officer comes inside the
bus and asks what is wrong with her
miriam acts strange to get the officer's
attention off-key
she is arrested and taken off the bus
while key and theo reach back hill
without detection
there the two meet a woman named
marichka who takes them to an old rusty
room for the night as soon as they get
inside kei's contraction gets worse and
she starts giving birth
theo helps her with it and within some
time she gives birth to a beautiful
little girl the two happily celebrate
the following morning they wake up to
sit in maricha banging on the door
they tell them that the fishes have
broken into the city and the national
guard have been called out to restore
order
outside several riots and shootouts are
taking place
key tries to hide her child from them
but they eventually see her murica tries
to tell theo and keep to not go with sid
because he is a bad person but sid
threatens them with a gun
as it turns out sid wants to turn theo
and keon for money marichka attacks sid
and the three narrowly escape
amidst the riots and shootouts in the
street they managed to get to marichka's
family they take great care of the baby
and key and agree to help them to get to
a boat
they put key in a wheelchair and run
outside the streets are in chaos bullets
fly everywhere as they make their way to
the boat but before they get there the
fishes take key away from them and kill
murica's associate however the fishes
are attacked by the british forces and
murica and theo managed to flee they run
amidst the shootouts and bomb explosions
and are soon separated
thiel goes around the buildings looking
for key in the child
he then goes upstairs and finds key with
her crying baby hiding in a corner
amongst other dead and injured people
luke is on the other side shooting at
the force from the window as theo
attempts to take key and the baby out
luke opens fire in theo's direction but
luke is killed a few moments later and
they managed to escape
as they come out of the room it explodes
the two finally get out of the place
with the baby as everyone who sees them
is stunned the shooting and explosion
stop as the people watch the baby in awe
a soldier orders everyone to cease the
firing some of them get down on their
knees to pray as the two get away the
shooting starts again but they managed
to flee and reunite with marijka
theo he and the baby get into the boat
and finally leave the harbor they see
fighter jets flying overhead and key is
worried that they are late theo assures
her that they will get to the tomorrow
ship
he sees blood and starts to freak out
claiming that she is bleeding but theo
says that it is his as it turns out that
luke had shot theo before they ran away
an injured theo teaches key to burp her
baby as he whimpers in pain he tells him
that she will name her baby dylan after
theo's late son
theo soon loses consciousness as he
looks around and calls his name
helplessly just then her face is
lightened up to see the tomorrow ship in
front of them
they have finally reached their
destination before the movie ends we
hear the sound of children laughing
suggesting that the world has gone back
to how it was
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching